[Music]
long coved a phenomenon which is still
puzzling researchers around the world
many people who were infected with
covid19 have had long-term problems
after recovering even if they weren't
very ill in the first place
the list of symptoms is long and
wide-ranging extreme tiredness shortness
of breath
heart palpitations chest pain and
problems with memory and concentration
many also are afflicted with chronic
pain
the severity of symptoms varies but many
have been left unable to deal with
everyday challenges like cleaning
grocery shopping and they report
problems communicating
treating long-covered patients requires
doctors to take into account both
physical and psychological symptoms
and to sometimes consider experimental
treatment like recuperation in salt
mines
this is your kovid 19 special on dw i'm
janelle dumalaon what exactly causes
long covid in this next report we meet
someone who has it and examine the
theories as to why she's experiencing it
have a look
you can't tell by looking at her but
every one of her movements takes immense
strength for a year now jennifer nails
can hardly do anything on her own
she has chronic fatigue syndrome after
covert 19.
he goes to form a financial plan i've
never felt this exhausted before in my
life
every couple of minutes her body forces
her to stop and rest even during our
interview the 43 year old needs to take
breaks over and over
for years now carmen scheibenborgen and
her team at charity berlin university of
medicine are among the few researchers
studying chronic fatigue syndrome the
scientists are familiar with the
symptoms which are similar to those of
infectious mononucleosis
not everyone who has covid19 and
developed long covert also show signs of
chronic fatigue syndrome it's only a
possible consequence
researchers currently have three
hypotheses on how and why cfs develops
first the immune hypothesis
the immune system gets confused it wants
to fight the sars cov2 virus but
overshoots permanently
there's a constant overreaction in the
blood vessels
too many antibodies and t cells on a
continuous basis
when the immune system is hard at work
we feel exhausted
everyone's familiar with the symptoms
from pain to lack of concentration and
other typical flu-like
all symptoms can come from the immune
system
so the immune or autoimmune hypothesis
can explain the whole clinical pattern
second the blood circulation hypothesis
the blood vessels in the body become
inflamed right down to the smallest
veins
they can no longer properly dilate and
constrict
the blood circulation is disturbed which
even affects the mitochondria the cell's
tiny powerhouses
the result is that organs and muscles
cannot function optimally and become
weak
if the vessels are not supplied with
blood then there won't be enough oxygen
in the tissues which in turn means the
body can't produce enough energy
this can quickly result in muscle pain
during exertion headaches and
concentration loss
third the nervous system hypothesis
in this case researchers believe that
the nerves cannot properly function
there's limited conductivity
the nervous system which also controls
unconscious bodily functions is under
constant stress
and that leads to dysfunction in the
entire body
[Music]
the nervous system is no longer
functional
the most typical example is the loss of
taste and smell which is also a function
of the nerves
but also memory loss and problems with
concentration
scientists believe that these three
mechanisms separately altogether could
trigger chronic fatigue syndrome
but because so little research has been
done it's still hard for doctors to know
how to effectively help patients like
jennifer
nails david strain is a senior clinical
lecturer at the university of exeter
medical school welcome back to the
program
david you have experienced long coved
yourself we last talked about that
earlier this year how are you doing now
i'm i'm doing much better i'm still not
100 but i'm fully functional at work and
i still do wake up with the pain i still
do get tired a lot quicker than i used
to do but on the most part making a
pretty good recovery
certainly glad to hear that but you said
back then that the natural history was
not clear yet do we know more now
we are getting more and more data as the
people who are making a full recovery
versus the people who are making partial
recovery but versus the people who are
not getting better at all and at the
moment the numbers appear to be a third
of each so a third of people who get
this seem to make a full recovery back
to normal no residual symptoms a third
of people make good enough recovery so
that they can go about their activities
as usual they go back to work they spend
time with the kids as normal um and then
there's a third of people that do appear
to be
still suffering very badly 12 or now 15
or 16 months after their original
infection
now one of the hypotheses about the
causes of long covid is that it's in the
mitochondria the powerhouse of the cells
in area in which you are doing research
of course can you tell us about your
findings there
and it's very early to say things for
definite we are seeing some evidence
that um actually in the report earlier
you were talking about the author
antibodies and there is some evidence of
the
auto antibodies that are actually
targeting uh mitochondria and there does
appear to be an overlap that the
mitochondria are not reproducing as well
and that fits very much with some of the
patients or the profile of some of the
patients who present with this that they
are
starting the day feeling okay they just
fatigue very very quickly and the
interplay between these autoimmune and
mitochondria does appear to be a big
factor
that is actually really promising
because if we can clarify exactly how
that's happening it does open itself to
treatments that are actually treating
the cause rather than at the moment we
are very much dealing with the symptoms
now chronic fatigue syndrome of course a
part of long covid is that the worst
manifestation of long covet that one can
get
well there are many different
manifestations and actually there are
some people whose fatigue isn't that bad
but are presented with lots of chest
pains or lots of palpitations but
for many uh 91 percent of people who get
long covered are troubled by this
fatigue and the fatigue itself can be
incredibly debilitating actually the
name chronic fatigue syndrome doesn't do
justice but just how bad these people
are experiencing it and as in your
report there are people who just can't
do simple tasks um the idea of chopping
some carrots has to be done in multiple
stages
and for those the worst bit about it is
there is no visual recognition um if
they had a big cuts if they had big
rashes if they had
something that you can say yes this is
the problem
it's much easier to
address that whereas because the fatigue
there's no way of measuring it there's
no way of observing it there's no real
test for it
then people very often
struggle to have the the severity of
their condition recognized
david strain is a senior clinical
lecturer at the university of exeter
medical school thank you very much
you're welcome
up next derrick williams with one of
your questions on long covid
what do we know about the reduction in
lung covered risk by vaccines
[Music]
the data shows that vaccines very
clearly help save lives and and spare
nearly all recipients from the worst
ravages of of covet 19 but
do they also reduce the chances of
developing possible long-term effects in
the weeks or the months
after you should have recovered um at
least one in ten people have those and
and we know from studies that even those
who have mild symptoms initially can go
on to develop what's called long covid
which is a wide range of chronic
complaints linked to infection with sars
cov2 that that for unclear reasons
persist in some people
knowing whether vaccines could also help
prevent long covid from developing
has therefore been a very pressing
question not just in terms of the
potential human cost
but but also because long coveted looks
set to have a huge impact
on national healthcare systems all over
the planet in years to come
so if vaccines could help prevent not
just serious initial disease but also
the development of of long covet and
breakthrough cases then
that would be a really huge bonus um and
on wednesday researchers published
evidence that they likely do
the major study led by scientists at
king's college in london
looked at information registered via an
app
by millions of adults in britain both
vaccinated and unvaccinated
in roughly the first six months of this
year and it found that in people who'd
been vaccinated but later tested
positive for covet 19 anyway
the chances of having symptoms for four
weeks or more after infection so long
covered were only around half that in
unvaccinated people
now that's not necessarily the last word
on the topic but it is a strong
indicator that vaccines don't just help
prevent serious disease
they also probably go a long way
towards keeping people who have
breakthrough infections from developing
long covet
[Music]
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon
[Music]
[Music]
you